ces deux sera de savoir que le public se
pose des questions sur des réseaux
d'influencé et que toute cette preuve
est frappée d'un interdit de publication
ça aussi je m'étais entendu avec le pq
au départ je veux je suis une
enquiquineuse va poser des questions
vous serez pas capable de m'arrêter là
ça c'est certain mais en plus de ça je
suis une adepte de la publicité
je m'étais bien entendu avec eux là
dessus puis j'ai eu le mandat derrière
de contester cette portion l'homme et la
commission n'a pas donné raison mais
c'est décevant de savoir que des réseaux
d'influencé se sont fait entendre à le
cloud saas et des savants pendant la
campagne électorale
ça a duré une semaine c'est décevant
vous parlez des chefs c'est une autre
question
les chefs savent et les chefs de parti
c'est pas des gens qui ont les mains
dans l'organisation la planification de
la conception d'une campagne de
financement en général moi je pense que
la vérité c'est pour la commission c'est
d'aller voir les données puis d'aller
voir qu'elle est quelles sont les
sources du financement d'un parti
politique
la question sera de savoir est-ce que
c'est sectorielle personnel quelles sont
les sources de financement d'un parti
politique
comment se comporte le contributeur des
vies ça je pense que si ce n'est pas en
alignant des histoires qu'on va trouver
une réponse satisfaisante pour la
démocratie
j'espère de la leur comme ça par une
sera par un quart alors probablement
l'occasion de le faire je le sais pas
mais ce qui est à faire un point ce
qu'est ce que vous retenez que le
bénéfice
des audiences publiques pour vous c'est
très important pour le public c'est
l'occasion pour le public de s'informer
de connaître d'apprendre d'être éduqué à
la chose publique c'est pour ça que mon
les auditions à huis clos où je peux pas
comprendre charge du processus de la
commission en étant une adepte des
auditions publiques puis une ennemie des
auditions confidentiel que vous savez
les avocats on est quand même on est bon
pour demander des ordonnances
maintenant après cette expérience le
j'ai trouvé que le public était
tellement mieux servis par les caméras
dans la salle pour voir ce qu'on fait
nous autres comme avant quand on peut
voir qu'est ce que les gens disent moi
je trouve ça important là je suis
devenue une adepte de la publicité des
débats principe cette commission gérard
de la difficulté à me convaincre d'aller
solliciter une ordonnance de non
publication